على عكسي والدته المحبه لطبق كبد الاوز
المسمن او يفاجغى منع الملك تشارلز من
تقديمه على موائد الاسره الملكيه قرروا
الملك جاء في رساله وجهها القصر الملكي
للجمعيه بيتا النشطه في مجال الرفق
بالحيوان وكعبون شكر للملك ارسلت الجمعيه
له صندوقا طبقا مزيفا من هذا النوع
يقدمه الشاف النباتي اليكسي جوتيه في لندن
يوصلنا هذا الطبق عبر تغذيه الطيور قصريه
لكي يصل حجم كبدها الى 10 اضعاف حجمه
الطبيعي ويعرف عن تشارلز الثالث في كفاح
طويل من اجل حمايه الطبيعه وهو كان من اشد
المنتقدين استهلاك طبق كبد الوزن المسمى
بدايه من عام 20 22 تقديم هذا طبق لتنضم
الى كاليفورنيا والهند واستراليا وغيرها
من الدول التي حضرت هذا طبق لاسباب التعلق
بالحقوق الحيوانات